hey guys welcome to a quick video just
showing off this website Python anywhere
dot-com if you visit that website this
is their little landing page here they
do have paid accounts but they also have
free accounts that you can just sign up
for their free account and pretty much
use everything the only thing they won't
let you do with a free account is do
outbound HTTP requests mostly probably
because people would abused it and do
you like DDoS is and stuff like that
with them so that's probably why but
anyway you can make a free account and
super cool super easy and I'm going to
show you guys some of this stuff that
you can do with in there and just as a
side note I'm not an affiliate or
anything there's no affiliate link I'm
just kind of showing it off they're not
paying me to do this or anything like
that I just think it's a really cool
website so anyway
when you log in you look something like
this you didn't buy an account you don't
have as many seconds as I do but anyway
so when you get there you have something
that looks like this you've got files
you've got consoles that you can run and
so it's a lot like having it is your own
pretty much VPS right so you but it
comes with just everything Python so if
you you know we're following the Amazon
Web Services tutorial video and you're
probably all pretty much all my
subscribers just are all about Python
right so I'm assuming that a lot of
people watching this or that's what
they're interested in anyways so I think
it's definitely a good good website to
show off real quick so they've got
everything Python here they've got two
seven two six three three and they've
also got the ipython PI pi and then also
you also have like you know your typical
bash right so your typical command line
where you can do all kinds of fun stuff
and not too much here but there's a few
things so you have that but also what
makes it nice is if you aren't looking
for a place to run you know your Python
scripts kind of like in cloud so to
speak you can do that with this website
and so like for example I'll go to my
files tab and I have this test up PI
script so we'll click on this and here
it is just a sample script of
my API one minute I'll have to authorize
this auth token though all right so I
got the often that'll at least work so
it's just this the script here is just
something that accesses my sentiment API
on sent decks and they'll feed through
like this text here so I'm super excited
he's just awesome sentiment analysis API
anyway so now you know we could do
anything we wanted like adding you know
like bar two for example and you can
edit the script so we can say this is 56
right and you can either just save the
script or you can hit save and run and
it's gonna run this script for you so
now it's running it's returning for
since it was somewhat positive of text
there but the best thing is you have to
do any that stuff I showed you with ADB
us anymore so we can close out of this
it's still running you can go to
dashboard and here is test PI still
running we can click on it probably see
more for us than we're there before
right so now it's you know halfway
through the page a little bit further
and so we can go back to our dashboard
and we can even log out so now we've
completely logged out we'll wait a few
seconds here and maybe I'll pause I'll
pause it and let a few more so you'll
see when it's a full screen of fours
alright it's probably all set someone
login and so you can see our stuff is
still running if I open this up here
indeed we have more than a full page of
fours I'm gonna go ahead and interrupt
this so stop spamming my website come
back to dashboard here and well come
over here and even though you know we
interrupted it we still want to kill it
so I'll hit kill that sounds horrible so
you can do that the other really neat
thing that you can do with one obviously
it's like your scripts are everywhere
right so you just need a web browser and
you can visit your scripts but the other
thing you can do is actually share the
consul's with somebody else so as you
code in one console so on else can view
what you're coding in that console at
the same time so obviously that's really
cool so if you wanted to like you know
collaborate with somebody you can share
the console and kind of see what
everybody's doing so it's actually
pretty pretty darn impressive actually
even just like the web you know
Python consoles is pretty cool so those
are just some basics it also has
obviously my sequel I'm not wondering if
I can get a list of all of the I've seen
it before here we go batteries included
I think yeah and so this has all like
that everything for Python to seven that
it's got installed here it's got
everything to six that it's guy and then
it's got a list of Python three three
stuff that it already has some of the
nice things about like all of this is
you can use all of these things that are
pre-installed like scythe on all that
stuff and it's already pre-installed
it's going to work right
so sometimes installing various things
can be very pious and annoying but you
don't have to worry about that here
because everything is done for you
including you know Django and all that
stuff too so really cool website a lot
of stuff that you can do with this it's
not too bad pricing wise though the
account that I currently have is like
five dollars a month or something and
you can already do a lot the reason why
I maxed out my seconds this time is I
ran a twitter twitter feed and through
it just for a little bit so just trying
to gauge how many seconds it would use
and that was it used quite a few seconds
to say the least I ran it for a few
hours but anyway neat website definitely
check them out
again I'm not not an affiliate or
anything like that I just really like
the website I think it's a good idea and
it's pretty neat so far all my
interactions with them have been pretty
good and the stuff that I see them
posting about and stuff it seems like
they're really on on top of it so that's
pretty neat they've got a pretty good
reliability that are improving the right
reliability now so I haven't really been
with them long enough to give a good
estimate of as far as their uptime but
you can check various websites you might
even be able to find something on their
forums they're pretty transparent about
everything that's going on so definitely
a cool website regardless of what you
plan to do with it even if you just want
to use their free account and be able to
code Python wherever you go
definitely something to look into so
anyway hopefully you guys found that
interesting as always thanks for
watching thanks for the support
subscriptions and until next